searchers in central Virginia are still
looking for two people swept away at by
floodwaters at least three people were
killed in Virginia and North Carolina as
remnants of subtropical storm Alberto
pounded the region rescuers in
Charlottesville Virginia found a
couple's car that was carried away one
person inside was killed and the other
is still missing another woman is
missing in nearby Madison County Kris
Van Cleave is in Charlottesville where
the rising water washed part of the road
away Chris good morning good morning
County officials are calling what
happened here a local emergency this
Creek normally just a trickle but you
can see how much damage it did during
this storm it ripped a 35 foot hole in
this road and is virtually cut off part
of this neighborhood search teams will
be back at it this morning after
spending all day Thursday combing
through high water and debris for the
missing couple whose Prius was washed
away
Lynchburg fire captain Alan Carr while
says the rushing waters quickly swept
two cars into the creek during the storm
the water was high enough and moving
fast enough that it took them off the
road now we hear it was six to ten
inches of rain that came down very fast
that created a flash flood and a whole
lot of water it went up over the road
you can see the debris is waist high
here and we are well above the creek bed
so you're talking about a torrent of
water that would have come on in a flash
and washed that car away the flooding
prompted about a dozen water rescues
here the storm damaged homes closed
schools and tore up dozens of county
roads here even washing away part of
this street massive mudslides in North
Carolina triggered a gas explosion
destroying this home and killing two in
Boone guys Gary Vicki powers watched as
the powerful floodwaters tore through
this an old barn it just took it down
the river there's nothing left with a
concrete slab on the bottom it was
pretty scary actually the county expects
will takes several days to fix this road
here and of course thunderstorms remain
in the forecast through the weekend the
other big concern potential flooding as
some of the rivers here are expected to
continue rising in the coming days Gail
there's been Cleve be careful very
dramatic pictures there thank you very
much